la place Jean Jaurès à Tours transformé
en campement de fortune c'est
l'initiative prise hier soir par
l'association
Utopia 56 pour alerter le grand public
sur le sort des mineurs étrangers sans
solution d'hébergement quand la
saturation du 115 laisse des enfants ou
de jeunes adultes à la rue c'est un
reportage de Sarah gros
c'est une manifestation à l'énergie
d'enfants et musicale pourtant depuis
quatre jours ces jeunes majeurs exilés
dorment sous une tente ils sont 6 à
avoir été expulsés de leur hébergement
d'accueil avant d'être pleinement
autonome une situation inédite dénoncée
par Utopia 56 l'association qui les
accompagne a réclamé au département de
nouvelles places en urgence mais les
négociations se sont traduites en échec
ce qu'on veut pas c'est de mettre la
misère contre la misère en fait c'est
pas mettre des jeunes qui ont à peine 18
ans à la rue pour héberger une femme
c'est pas une solution en fait c'est
qu'il y a pas assez de place donc il
faudrait ouvrir plus de place et pas
mettre des personnes à la rue pour
pouvoir en accueillir plus
hier soir les jeunes et l'association
ont installé un campement revendicatif à
Jean Jaurès une quatrième nuit dehors
pour Alassane Camara ce guinéen vient
tout juste d'avoir 18 ans étudiant en
dernière année de CAP il est très
inquiet pour la poursuite de ses études
ou maintenant vu que on n'a pas on a
plus de toi et on n'a pas
du coup ça va être très très compliqué
pour moi pour réviser parce qu'avec la
situation au campement c'est pas du tout
tranquille tu en as des soucis pour
dormir de pas tu dors pas bien et des
fois il y a l'orage comme le vendredi
passé il y avait l'orage on a vraiment
galéré et du coup c'était très très
compliqué pour nous on n'a pas pu dormir
une fatigue mais les deux peurs et
d'incertitude que partage une dizaine
d'autres exilés face à l'augmentation du
nombre de jeunes à la rue l'association
n'est plus en mesure d'accueillir les
nouveaux arrivants qu'ils soient majeurs
ou bien mineur ce jeune guinéen a 15 ans
il dort aussi dehors depuis quelques
semaines
je peux pas dormir
j'ai la stress aussi alors que les
dispositifs d'accueil saturent le nombre
de mineurs non accompagné continuent
d'augmenter en 2023 14 782 MNA ont été
recensés sur le territoire national